Go, ha.
And drop.
Whatever you're curious
about, dive into it,
understand it, and
then rip it apart.
When I was 10 years old, I
took my first hip-hop class.
I naturally went
against the grain
and that ended up
being my magic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For the first time ever,
I'll be sharing my secrets
and techniques to
my creative process.
Let's go, girls, performance.
You will learn the ins and
outs of how to discover
your true voice as a creative.
There's so many
different ways you
can use movement to kind
of unfold the next group.
I'm going to use
the curtain effect.
The girls have gone
from covering the boys
into two straight lines on
the sides within eight counts.
Just feels energetic,
it feels surprising,
and it really makes a smooth
and seamless transition
for the next group.
Let's break down the power
of eye contact to camera.
I've told her that the
camera is a piece of meat
and she hasn't eaten in days.
In her eyes, she's
telling the story.
And as a viewer, we're now
mesmerized by her performance.
Going drop and
chop, smooth, pop.
I haven't always been confident.
The truth is, it's been
such a long journey.
Growing up, I always
felt like an outcast.
You know, I didn't look
like a commercial dancer,
so I kind of took that and
turned it into my superpower.
It's about looking at
yourself and thinking,
"What makes me unique?"
And once you can discover that,
appreciate it, and put it out
into the world, then you're
really using your voice.
I really believe
that's what it's about
is understanding what's
within, understanding
what you stand for.
Understanding how you
want to change the world.
Because that's what dance does.
Good.
Cool.
It changes the world.
You can change the world.
I'm Parris Goebel, and
this is my MasterClass.